if the analysts are right the oil slump
has some way to go with $20 even $10 oil
seen as the next key levels when Brent
last broke through $100 in September
2014 US shale production was soaring
OPEC output was boosted by Libya and
Chinese demand was waning four months
later with Brent edging below 50 dollars
the impact on Russia's economy came into
focus
Fitch cut the country's credit rating
citing the plunging oil price as a key
factor last week with Brent hovering
around $30 BP announced it would cut an
additional 4,000 jobs highlighting the
pressure on the oil majors so where do
we go from here
we know oil exporting nations like Iraq
Venezuela and Nigeria have been under
pressure but now even Saudi Arabia is
feeling the pinch and is being forced to
cut spending at the corporate level
ExxonMobil Chevron shell and Statoil
of all reduced investment ConocoPhillips
losses close to two billion dollars each
quarter for every $10 drop in prices
according to Barclays of course cheap
oil also comes with benefits India Egypt
and Indonesia have been able to slash
fuel subsidies worth almost 500 billion
dollars in 2014 according to the
International Energy Agency airlines are
getting a boost as our car makers and
it's a positive for consumers unless of
course falling prices lead to
deflationary cycles at another headache
for the central bankers